for those people that are watching this
that aren't sure what's going on in
China there's a gajillion videos despite
what Apple's doing with airdrop out
there so we've got about a minute's
worth of compilation for you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I mean it's just unbelievable it's like
half of what was happening in Canada
over the summer throwing a little squid
games and a couple other dystopian
movies and and that's what you've got
um Melissa obviously we're not we're I
think we're all in agreement the U.S
isn't going to do much about this but do
the Chinese people have a chance like is
there any chance they can create any
sort of change themselves or is this
going to sort of be like what's going on
in Iran it's like it kind of happens for
a while and then it dies down and the
regime never changes
um I'm not optimistic about about any
change per se but you know this is
significant what what has happened over
the weekend with these protests this is
the largest display of public Defiance
against the regime since Tiananmen
Square protest in 1989.
um and to see such widespread Civil
Disobedience at the same time is is
quite striking in China in a place like
China
um what I what I will say is that
because these protests are actually very
targeted what the people want is to get
out of this Perpetual lockdown situation
I mean they are frustrated in xinjiang
for example they had been in lockdown
for 100 days straight and and many of
these cities like Beijing Shanghai
people are starving I mean in in the
land of abundance right supposedly the
Chinese Communist Party pulled so many
people out of poverty they're all middle
class and wealthy now
people are actually starving because of
lockdowns people have died because of
lockdowns as we saw in the fire that
killed some people so people are
frustrated they have the that's the end
of what they can tolerate and they're
they're rising up but at the end of the
day the Chinese state power and
surveillance apparatus is so perfected I
mean you you need a code to even travel
to you know to a certain place and into
certain buildings and if you don't scan
that code you're not going to be allowed
in and they can use this kind of
technology that was originally meant for
controlling the epidemic to actually
curtail movement and and we saw that an
example of this actually last summer
when they were able to prevent protests
for a bank run
um using the the actual software that
was meant to monitor the infections so I
I'm not optimistic about any kind of
higher up kind of change you know in
terms of toppling the government in
terms of challenging the regime's whole
and Power that's not going to happen
China is is is is still stable in that
sense because of the the way it's
structured but I think that what we will
see is probably loosening up a covert
restrictions that's probably the best
case scenario for for the Chinese people